>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Grant Harris: So, good afternoon.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
I am Grant Harris.
I am head of the European
Reading Room
over in the Jefferson
Building across the street.
Together with the Embassy of Italy
and the Italian Cultural Institute,
we are delighted to
welcome our special guest,
distinguished professor Salvatore
Settis who will discuss his timely
and acclaimed book,
"If Venice Dies."
Let me mention that the
Library of Congress is proud
of its 400,000 volumes
from or about Italy.
It includes an extensive collection
of monographs on the subjects
of Italians in the United
States, for example.
We acquire each year much
of the best research level
materials from or about Italy.
And we are proud to have the works
of Professory Settis
in that collection.
I counted well over 50
items in our collections
where he's written maybe
a forward, or edited,
or curated so we're very
pleased to have you here today.
In talking about the collections
let me also mention the two people
within the library who have helped
with this very much, Tirus Spiegel,
if just raise your hand there,
in the European Division.
And Lucia Wolf who is
our specialist for Italy.
And if you have questions
about using the collections,
please get hold of
Lucia Wolf now or later.
The European Division is
responsible for providing reference
and for developing the
library's collections relating
to continental Europe and Lucia
does that for Italy, and Malta,
and Italian materials
from Switzerland,
Vatican City, and San Marino.
I think I've listed
most of it right.
Now after the lecture we will
have a few minutes for questions
and answers before the book signing.
We hope you have a
pleasant time here today
and that you'll come back
and use the collections.
Please turn off your cell
phones and recording devices
for the duration of the program.
Also be aware that this event is
being recorded for a later webcast.
Renato Miracco, the cultural attache
at the Italian Embassy
cannot be with us today.
He was instrumental in
putting this together.
Unfortunately he has a family
bereavement back in Italy
so we hold Renato and his
family in our thoughts today.
I welcome Michael Wise,
co-founder of New Vessel Press,
and publisher of the English
translation of "If Venice Dies."
New Vessel Press specializes
in making foreign works
available to English speakers.
"If Venice Dies" has been ably
translated by Andre Naffis-Sahely.
Michael Wise has been a foreign
correspondent for Reuters
and the "Washington Post."
He is the author of a book
on German architecture
and his writing has appeared in many
publications that I personally like,
"The New York Times," "The Wall
Street Journal," "The New Yorker,"
"The Atlantic," and
"Foreign Policy."
That's quite a list.
That's not all though.
So I would welcome Michael to speak
to us now and introduce the speaker.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Wise: Thank
you very much.
We are very grateful to
the Library of Congress
for arranging this program.
I'm co-founder with Ross
Ufberg of New Vessel Press
and we're extremely
pleased to be the publisher
of the English translation
of Salvatore Settis' book
which appeared two years ago in
Italy as [foreign language spoken]
and now as "If Venice Dies,"
translated by Andre Naffis-Sahely.
Salvatore Settis is an
archeologist, and art historian,
and former director of both
the Getty Research Institute
of Los Angeles and the Scuola
Normale Superiore of Pisa.
He's currently the chairman of the
Louvre Museum Scientific Council
and can be considered the
conscience of Italy for his role
in spotlighting the
country's neglect
of its national cultural heritage.
And I think you'll soon
understand why that is
when you hear him speak today
about his concerns that he
so cogently lays out
in "If Venice Dies."
Washingtonians may remember that
he delivered the Mellon lectures
at the National Gallery
of Art in 2001,
and he also gave the
Isaiah Berlin Lectures
at the Ashmolean at Oxford in 2000.
His research interests
are centered on ancient
and Renaissance art history and
his many publications include
"The Future of the Classical,"
[Foreign Language spoken],
and he was co-editor of
"The Classical Tradition."
He has served as chair
of Italy's high council
for cultural heritage and landscape.
And his most recent book,
[Foreign Language spoken],
deals with the current debate about
constitutional reform in Italy
in which Professor Settis has
been extremely active ahead
of a referendum to be held
in Italy in early December.
He finds time as well to curate
exhibitions including last year's
opening pair of shows at the
Fondazione Prada in both Milan
and in Venice about
classical sculpture.
And he's also now working on
an exciting new exhibition
that will be held in Rome
in 2018 of the collection
from the Museo Torlonia, the largest
private collection of classical
and Greek Roman sculpture
[inaudible] in the world.
As an example of this impressive
array will be shown atop the
[Foreign Language spoken] in Rome
and we would be very fortunate
if it comes to the
United States as well.
Finally, I'd be remiss
as his American publisher
if I didn't urge you to
buy a copy of his book
which is on sale outside.
The book has received
considerable acclaim,
most recently a wonderful
review in the "Washington Post."
And as you'll hear now, "If
Venice Dies" is an eloquent appeal
to save the soul of one of
the world's greatest cities
and a wake-up call for us
all to heed what's happening
to our own lives and
what could happen
to historic cities everywhere.
[ Applause ]
>> Salvatore Settis:
Thank you, Michael,
for this generous introduction.
I'm particularly glad to be here.
And thank you all for inviting me
to give a talk here about my book
and about Venice more generally.
I'm very grateful to
the Italian Embassy
and to Renato Miracco
particularly and Angela [Inaudible]
who is here now, and to
the Library of Congress,
particularly to Lucia Wolf and Tirus
Spiegel for organizing this event.
And I particularly like
to thank Michael Wise
for translating my book in English.
My lecture is, you will understand
quite soon, is based on my book
but not identical with my book.
By way of introduction let
me make two short remarks.
First, while my book's focus
from the title on Venice,
it is not only about Venice.
It is about the destiny of
historical cities around the world,
in Italy but not just in Italy.
Second point, "If Venice
Dies," putting death
in the title is not necessarily
a good idea but I what I wanted
to stress is that death is a good
vantage point where from we may look
at trauma, at problems of life.
So as in private life when we have a
trauma from some death of a mother,
father, of a person who is dear to
us, this will bring us to think more
about our life and
in different terms.
So "If Venice Dies," this is not
just to comply with the [inaudible]
of death in Venice, but to
reflect what will happen,
what might happen if Venice dies.
And just to start with, what you see
on the screen is not
Venice but Las Vegas.
[ Laughter ]
Of course you may recognize the
proximity of different buildings,
the Rialto Bridge which
is much nicer
than this one and the Doge's Palace.
Okay. Cities die in three ways.
When a relentless enemy
destroys them
like the Romans did
with Carthage in 146 BC.
When a foreign nation
installs itself with force,
driving away the natives
and their gods
like the [inaudible] land before
it was transformed into Mexico City
and wiped out in 1521
by the conquistadors.
Or when the inhabitants of a given
city lose the memory of themselves
and without realizing it they
become strangers to themselves.
They become their own enemies.
This was the case for Athens
which, after the glory
of the classical polis and evidence
of culture, art, and history opened
up by the likes of Sophocles,
Euripides, Pericles, [Inaudible],
and so forth and so on, lost
first it's political independence
and later ended up forgetting
every memory of itself.
We often tend to consider Athens as
unchanged the remaining centuries,
and able and tend to believe that
it flowed with renewed splendor
when Greece became
independent in 1827.
But this is not the case.
It was the end of the twelfth
century when the [inaudible],
Michael Choniates,
arrived from Constantinople
as the new bishop of Athens.
He was shocked, as he tells us in a
text which preserved, he was shocked
at the terrible ignorance
of the Athenians.
He says, "They no longer
knew anything
of ancient glories
of their own city.
They cannot even identify the
[inaudible] which are still intact.
They were not able to
indicate where [Inaudible],
or Plato, or Aristotle had taught.
The Parthenon was at the time a
Christian church which was covered
in icons and where
liturgical songs were heard
and incense filled the air.
It was [inaudible] cathedral.
It was plundered repeatedly
by Italians, by Florentines
and Venetians particularly, without
the thing as lifting their finger
to defend the Parthenon
or the monuments.
When Athens was [inaudible]
by the Turks in 1456,
three years after Constantinople,
the Parthenon was transformed
into a mosque as you can
see here and even the name
of the city was forgotten.
What remained was a small village
with outgrowing here and there
and Athenians, reduced to a few
thousand people called it Satinee
[phonetic spelling],
Satinus [assumed spelling],
a mispronunciation of the name.
So even, Athens had
lost even its name.
But Athenians had begun to forget
themselves long before this time.
Already by around 1430 AD, the
new Platonic philosopher, Plautus,
who lived very close
to the Acropolis,
tells of having seen Athena,
the goddess of the Parthenon,
in a dream, who, having been
driven from her seat asked
for hospitality in Plautus' house.
This nostalgic dream
clearly conveys decline
of a culture and its self-awareness.
Now today we have forgotten
that even Athens eventually
forgot itself.
But perhaps we should recall the
darkness of the forgotten memory
if we want to avoid suffering
in our contemporary world
the same affliction.
Now we come to Venice,
a special city,
greatly loved and very fragile.
We all know the monumental
areas frequently visited
by tourists including ourselves even
if we have never explored
its [foreign language spoken]
or minor churches which
are extraordinarily rich
in urban and artistic merit.
Let me mention very briefly some
unique characteristics of Venice
such as an urban framework
which has evolved
over centuries always maintaining
only two means of getting
about for people and wares,
by foot or by waterway.
An extraordinary richness
of monuments or works of art
which reflect the enormous
prosperity of the [inaudible].
The constant decrease in
the resident population,
which I will come to later, the
continual increase of mass tourism
which invades most famous
areas of the city, and finally,
the fashion of having a second home
in Venice which most of us would
like to have as many have which
has the effect of inflating prices
and transforming Venice
into a city of second homes
which often remain empty
for almost the whole year.
Venice is enclosed in its
lagoon like a pearl in an oyster
but few understand the nature
between the lagoon and Venice.
The city extends into 118
islands linked by bridges
but to this should be added
other islands such as San Giorgio
or Torcello, accessible
only by water.
City, islands, and lagoon make
up an ecosystem unparalleled
for the balance between natural
environment and human places.
Lagoon has never been for Venice
either a limit or a neutral space.
It has been and it is, it should be,
the very condition of its existence.
And this transforms itself over
time in harmony with the city,
reflecting its beauty and
its history with the sort
of counter melody [foreign language
spoken] I would say in Italian
without which even the
voice of Venice would fade.
This intimate union was
represented in maps.
For example, in the plan
by Benedetto Bordone, 1528,
which the islands of the lagoon and
the ring of land around the city
from Mestre to Lido, were considered
as a sort of periphery [inaudible]
into the urban dimension by means of
accurate [inaudible] in indicators.
In this plan we already
see, for example, Marghera,
which is highlighted on
the corner of top left,
where a place I will mention later.
Marghera is indicated by
name so it does belong
to the urban space
although it is rather
on the terra firma
than in Venice itself.
The territory of the community of
Venice, [Foreign Language spoken],
in current administrative
[inaudible] includes a vast area
of mainland of which Marghera,
Mestre, and other areas is shown
on the slide including the
Tessera airport are part.
And the population is
moving towards this areas
in recent decades especially the
younger generations but mostly,
not because they like
it better there,
but because it's much less expensive
and they don't have enough
money to live in [inaudible].
If we look at the population
statistics for Venice [inaudible],
we see a noteworthy drop of 100,
000 fewer inhabitants
in the last few decades.
But if we distinguish,
as it's necessary,
the mainland from the
historical center,
we see that the situation
is much more dramatic.
You have the statistics as reported
in my book in the English edition,
which is updated by in
relation to the Italian edition,
but I add for this
lecture a [inaudible] slide
with the statistics count
on June thirteenth [inaudible]
a few days ago but a few less,
that now we are at 54
thousand and a few hundred.
Now we know that 2.6
people on average move away
from Venice every single day.
All the progress I was
talking about had to be seen
against this very worrying backdrop.
Decrease of population in Venice has
started [inaudible] in other words,
doesn't necessarily
mean increase in numbers
of mainland Venice inhabitants
as shown by the chart here.
You see the historic center is in
blue and the terra firma is in red.
The [inaudible] of terra
firma is declining.
Now if Venice is to die, it will not
be on account of enemy invasions.
It will because most
of Venetians and most
of Italians have forgotten
about Venice.
And forgetting [inaudible]
for a community today,
that's not only mean
forgetting one's own history.
It also means the lost understanding
of the specific role of every city
with respect to others of
the uniqueness and diversity
of every city which is
perhaps no other city
in the world possesses
as much as Venice.
Which is that I think
as necessary in a world
which the urban dimension
is not only grown enormously
but has been distorted by the
growth of gigantic mega-cities,
human [inaudible] where in name
of productivity tens of millions
of people gather often condemned
to conditions and patterns of life
that have little to do
with the original sense
and spirit of the city.
Let me mention as an example
a place where I've never been,
Chongqing in China which in
1930 had 600,000 inhabitants
and today has almost 34
million people living in it.
Thirty-four million
people in last few decades.
The very notion of a city, a
cultural creation which is a hotbed
of thought and civilization,
elaborately for social relations
and culture tends to become
the shell of the shapeless
of apparently spontaneous
[inaudible] by small,
wealthy minorities while the
majority of citizens are holed
up in squalid housing
blocks and are considered
of not the citizens
but this workforce.
This development is coming
about with unequal speed
in various parts of the world.
[Inaudible] to perceive
the difference
between the old former [inaudible]
and the [inaudible]
idea of megalopolis.
In Italy distinction between the old
city of citizens and the new form
of worker ants which are also a
necessary consumer ants is expressed
in the harsh contrast
between historical centers
and peripheries which besiege them.
Having grown up in [inaudible]
in less than a few decades
under the push of property
speculation in land rents,
Italian [inaudible] are in general
[inaudible] by an architecture
of extremely poor aesthetic quality.
[Inaudible] with their respective
historical centers by the poverty
of spaces for social life.
In hilltop cities like Sienna we
still see its form from far away
but in other cities,
like for instance Naples,
we see that they are [inaudible]
by an apparently unstoppable urban
sprawl that actually translates
in a relentless erosion of
the varied idea of a city,
or more accurately,
immense metastasis in lots
of indecipherable growth
entailing the destruction
of everything with
surrounding spaces.
The center is old,
city, countryside,
harmony which made Italy the garden
of Europe has died a violent death
and at the hands, not of invaders,
but of the Italians themselves.
Cities are not only made of
buildings and roads but of men
and women with their cultural,
religious, and social connections.
Urban form has been created and
modified over time according
to powerful mechanism which Henri
Lefebvre has termed "the production
of space," [foreign
language spoken].
The space in which we live, being
by its very nature a social space,
is indeed the product of people and
results from economic processes,
from political decisions,
from cultural choices
which come together.
Therefore the space for industrial
civilization is radically different
from that of another culture.
For this reason Venice, with
its unique history and relation
with the lagoon, [inaudible]
of the centuries [inaudible]
itself a culture and social space
of [inaudible] and originality
with very few possible comparisons.
Beyond the visible city of buildings
and roads there is
an invisible city,
a city I would say with a soul.
It defined by a double relationship,
a relationship of the city
with the human body, i.e. the
citizens who inhabit that city.
And there's a relationship with
nature, the surrounding countryside,
in the case of Venice, the lagoon.
And it entails a relationship
of proportions between the body
of the citizen and
the body of the city.
I would say that the body
of the city mimics, repeats,
enhances the citizen's body.
It welcomes and guides the citizen.
It echoes the voice, and steps,
and leads him or her to streets
and bridges, to [inaudible] grace
with a lift and flow that in Venice,
as much as elsewhere
historic cities,
is a collective creation involving
aristocrats and merchants, artisans
and sailors, glass workers and
[inaudible], men and women.
In its long history Venice conquered
the right to the city for those
who dwell in it which in this city
also means the right to nature,
a right to the wellbeing of the
lagoon which has been integral
to Venetian life and
history for millennia.
Today though hundreds
of million people live
in [inaudible] areas called
[inaudible] by tens of millions
of people, areas made to increase
the production for goods for all
and to increase the profits
for a few people without limit.
And this process of
concentrating people
into giant beehives seems
destined to expand in the future.
It's difficult, at least for me,
to believe that those who live
in such [inaudible] better
lives than those who live
in historic cities reflecting
[inaudible] urban culture
such as Venice.
Yet mega-cities have become an
[inaudible] icon for our time
and are conventionally identified
with the very idea of modernity.
Yet do we really want to think
that megalopolis will supplant
all other urban forms forever?
Or will it instead be worthwhile
to keep other alternatives in mind
when we think of the
city of the future?
Do we wish, that's the
question, to nurture
or to destroy the multiplicity
and diversity for urban forms?
Venice and Chongqing are
two quite different models
of communal living thus in order
to better understand Chongqing
we must inevitably think also
of Venice.
Like megalopolis the
skyscraper is taken as an icon
of modernity especially
where skyscrapers are not
so common, such as in Italy.
And it is perhaps for
this reason that as part
of the project presented
the Venice [inaudible]
in 2010 [inaudible] architect with
Italian assistance to save Venice
from the high waters by
surrounding it by what,
a corona of skyscrapers
built on artificial reefs
which surrounds the city,
protects it from the seas
and populates it with Venetians.
Let me read from the site
of this [inaudible] study,
the [inaudible] text.
"When looking at the not so
distant future, they say,
we have a few certainties.
Sea level will rise and global
warming will affect climate.
Aqualta 2016, that's
the name of the project,
is an attempt to describe
this scenario.
How do we protect the
city from the sea?
What if we consider bringing a new
[inaudible] a linear city merging
from the water around
Venice, a new frame
and a new perspective
toward Venice to preserve
and enjoy the historical city.
What does this city look like?
If it's along waterfront
stretching in front of Venice
and if the weather is
warmer, why not think of it
as the Italian Copa Cabana."
[ Laughter ]
I'm quoting.
"A long beach submerged
by tropical vegetation."
What a nice view.
What a nice perspective.
"A vision of a vision,"
they continue.
"The old Venice overlooking
the Bay of Ipanema.
The new town beaches and houses
will have the glorious backdrop
of an unseen Venice."
So for the quote.
Let's highlight two
points of this text.
On one hand Venice is being
[inaudible] on two other latitudes
like might be sort of
periphery of Rio de Janeiro.
On the other it is no
longer a city which to live
but rather a city to
observe from afar.
In order to enjoy the view of the
historical city indeed it is good
to think of it as glorious backdrop
for whoever will live in skyscrapers
which is the real place, the
place for real human beings.
In a vision such as this
the Venetians would stay.
The historical city would
be like fish in an aquarium.
[ Laughter ]
A [inaudible] of skyscrapers was
also in the mind of a former mayor
of Rome who in 2010 send me
[inaudible] Venice [inaudible] said
officially he wanted to
make Rome's periphery denser
by constructing a column of
skyscrapers meant to rise
above the dome of St. Peter's
which so far is [inaudible] the
height limit for business in Rome.
It will then, he said, have
a Rome of skyscrapers next
to the most important
city center in the world.
That's in the words of
a former mayor of Rome.
Skyscrapers in Rome, skyscrapers
in Venice, skyscrapers really based
in Milan, as you see here
in the on the screen.
The party line goes as follows:
In Italy in the last few decades
there have been too few high quality
architectural projects.
Now is therefore the moment
to make up for lost time.
This fever to update is
a provincial obsession
that makes the skyscraper the symbol
[inaudible] of modernity forgetting
that actually skyscrapers
were really connection
with anything New York
or Chicago 100 years ago.
Not now. Therefore,
even a great architect
such as Renzo Piano is now
building a skyscraper in Turin
which according to the
original project should be,
as in this picture, taller
than the Mole Antonelliana
and thereby breaking
city regulations.
After many protests the height
was reduced by one foot.
[ Laughter ]
A ridiculous difference
which is not the sign
of respect but instead as near.
However with these skyscrapers today
in Italy means updating Italian
cities to a century ago or better,
not imitating New York or Chicago
but Chongqing, Singapore, or Dubai.
I hope you will forgive me if
I continue to prefer to Venice
by Odoardo Fialetti, a
rather glorious version
of the city even without
skyscrapers.
Now before speaking of
more disturbing situations,
I would briefly like to mention very
briefly the [inaudible] safeguarding
that [inaudible] heritage
currently in place in Italy.
Nuns of all Italian states that
existed before the [inaudible]
of Italy mid-nineteenth century,
nuns of all the Italian states
including the Republic of Venice
and oldest in the world, and they
acquired new strength and impetus
from the notion of
[foreign language spoken]
or cultural heritage created
during the French Revolution
and imported into Italy.
Current laws are restoring
to the basis of legislation
from the twentieth century.
Let me only mention that legislation
on landscape, the first law,
first Italian law on landscape
is dated 1920 and the Minister
for Education was the greatest
Italian philosopher of that time,
Benedetto Croce when
a great philosopher
like Benedetto Croce
could be a minister.
A very important turning
point was the constitution
of the Italian Republic in
1947 where Article 9 reads,
"The republic, the Italian Republic,
safeguards natural landscape
and historical [inaudible]
of the nation."
For the first time in 1947 the
principle of heritage entered
into the founding principles
of the constitution
of the modern state although there
are precedents in the constitution,
particularly of the
Weimar Republic in Germany.
Notwithstanding the constitution
and the laws, in Venice [inaudible]
with the erosion of the very idea
of a city takes place also in Italy.
Above all and the destruction
centuries old armory
between city and countryside.
What elsewhere is countryside
for Venice is the lagoon
where the waters of the sea
mix with those of the rivers.
Lagoon and city beckon together
from a complex [inaudible] system
through are preserved
and implemented in time
through mechanisms of surveillance
and management over the waters.
The [foreign language spoken],
created in about 1510 had been
unfortunately abolished two years
ago by the Italian government.
Now today Venice appears
to many as a city
like any other whose development
is only limited by the lagoon.
The lagoon is seen as an empty
space, as a limit to the city.
It has therefore been
proposed to save Venice
from isolation while the beginning
of the twentieth century the
futurists sought to fill in
and tarmac over the Grand Canal
[inaudible] they foresee a Venice
[inaudible] underground system in
order to create a single mega-city
out of the three with
underground lines
which would run under the lagoon.
In shorter distance
Venice increasingly looks a
dramatically outdated.
There are vast territorial
restructuring projects whereby the
city would change its
name in English.
Veneto City or Venice Land.
Huge built up areas
-- I'm just quoting.
They're serious about it.
I'm joking but they're not.
Huge built up areas where
one imagines that real life,
that of production and consumption
of goods, is carried out in areas
of new construction while historical
Venice could be an exciting sort
of periphery on city
shore I think back.
Such a Venice would be
actually a sort of Disneyland,
more like the creations of Las Vegas
than the city of the Doges Palace
and of St. Mark's Basilica.
This process of Disney-fication
had been announced,
pre-announced many years ago and
I found an article in 1981 by one
of the leading professors
of architecture
in the Polytechnical di Milano
published in 1981 in the journal,
"[Foreign Language spoken],"
whereby he said that, quote,
"The transformation of Venice into a
Disneyland could signal the passage
to a more creative, more cheerful,
and more festive way of living."
Actually nothing in the
world goes against the model
of urban development based
on urban densification
and architecture verticalization.
Protected by the lagoon [inaudible]
symbiotic relationship this city
appears a happy island
in a world afflicted
by uncontrollable metamorphosis.
According to architectural
historian, Manfredo Tafuri, quote,
"Venice is an unbearable
challenge to the world of modernity
that elicits assaults by
developers, ambitions by architects,
and massive invasions of tourists."
And then, "All you need is to
stop for a few hours in Venice
to be threatened, gun to your
head, by the gusts of a modernity
that takes the form of mega-ships
almost the familiar skyscrapers
within the city itself.
[Inaudible] of consumer reminder
I will show a few slides taken
from real life in Venice.
A status of consumerism, the
cruise ships which invade the city,
destroying its skyline better
resemble a huge Las Vegas hotels
than ships.
Like in Las Vegas, ships
with thousands of beds,
4,000 beds for instance, pass
themselves off as exclusive luxury
but are holiday machines that
sell illusions passing the most
[inaudible] of its
highly personalized ships
that are [inaudible] and try their
best to look like a convention city.
The big moment of glory
for these monster ships is
when they can show off
their [inaudible] arrogance
of being an artificial city
forcing their way into the docks
of San Marco challenging the
[Foreign Language spoken]
with their garish bulk.
The mega-ships penetrate the
heart of Venice to see its beauty
but they overshadow and damage
the city, changing its perception.
To mention but one, the ship called
Divina [assumed spelling] is 220
feet high, twice as tall as the
Doge's Palace, and 1,094 feet wide,
twice the breadth of
Piazza San Marco.
At times up to a dozen liners have
entered the lagoon in a single day.
Mega-ships are only -- so you can be
in Venice and see things like this.
Mega-ships are only the most
visible sign [inaudible]
that devastates Venice social
and [inaudible] family.
Eight million tourists
pour into Venice's streets
and canals each year to
the point that tourists
out number Venetians 140 to 1.
Such a disproportion has
impacted the [inaudible]
and is [inaudible] altering
the population and the economy.
[Inaudible] from the island city
and thus will remain a shuttered
to serving of [inaudible],
restaurants,
and shop selling glass
souvenirs and carnival masks.
Alarm at this state of affairs
led to recent UNESCO decision
to place Venice on
its World Heritage
In Danger List unless
substantial progress
to [inaudible] city is
made by February 2017.
In Italy these ships
had the terrible habit
of passing dangerously
close to the coast.
After the ship wreck of the
Costa Concordia in January 2012
that left 32 people dead
off the coast of Tuscany,
the Italian government ruled
that major ships must stay
at least two miles away from shore
to prevent similar
occurrences in the future.
And this has been enforced
with one exception,
Venice where there is no limit.
I think that this is very
telling, this inability to deal
with the problems of Venice.
Besides the horrible
[inaudible] the mega-ships,
one can also add the significant
decrease of water quality.
A high risk of pollution and the
subsequent spilling of hydrocarbons
in the heart of the city.
It is that the increases with number
of cruise liners that are allowed.
Authorities try to deny
the fact of this pressure
and there is no clear
data, no official data
on pollution dust particles.
Apparently 500 tons of dust
particles dumped by ships
in Venice in every single year.
Or on the very [inaudible] data
on the presence of benzopyrene,
highly toxic chemical being
[inaudible] in the lagoon.
The [inaudible] contradicts
the model of modernity
with the [inaudible]
skyscraper of this symbol.
On the other hand though a very
concrete project for the skyscraper
in Venice and particularly in
Marghera has been seriously launched
by Pierre Cardin, a
French fashion designer
who is actually Pietro
Cardin, born in Treviso.
His Palais Lumiere would cost
one and a half billion Euros,
licensed 820 feet high and
covering an area of 43 acres
in Marghera's dilapidated
industrial zone.
Three interlacing towers, 60
habitable floors in western fashion
and the offices, shops, [inaudible],
conference places, [inaudible],
major stores and sports grounds,
a vertical city presented
as a unique occasion to reclaim
an industrial area in decline
but also a dramatic transformation
brings the skyline high,
more than twice the Campanile de
San Marco, that would be built
in defiance of all
the urban [inaudible].
Impossible not to see it from the
Piazza San Marco especially by night
because if it is to be
a Palais Lumiere is has
to be very visible by night.
Not only this, it would also cut
across flight paths violating
the height restriction imposed
by the National Civil
Aviation Board by three,
by [inaudible], by 360 feet.
So if this is ever built,
please don't fly to Venice.
But fortunately the project
had been abandoned recently.
And even the very negative public
opinion in Italy and elsewhere.
But Pierre Cardin came so far
as to advertise apartments
in his Palais Luminere in
shop windows in France.
And the dark stain you see
here, you see, what is this?
This is Venice, same profile.
Venice as a backdrop.
[Inaudible] to increase the price
of the different apartments
especially on the highest floors.
So now the question is why,
what to the Palais Lumiere
and the cruise lines down the
Grand Canal have in common?
They are, some say, good
opportunities for Venice
but I ask why, if we want to
take tourists to Venice by sea,
it is done with high
polluting cruise liners?
Why over the enormous area he would
have at his disposal does Cardin,
or Cardin, not construct two,
or three, or five smaller towers
with the same purpose of this area?
Because he wants it to
be visible from afar.
There's only one possible answer.
In all these cases violating Venice
is not [inaudible] of consequence.
It is rather the heart
of the project.
It is as some have said essential
to [inaudible] this larger city
which irritates the
priests of modernity,
that's Tafuri general
commenting on the process.
A larger city which irritates
the priests of modernity much
as an unwilling virgin
might irritate a womanizer
who thinks himself
irresistible like Don Giovanni
who thinks himself irresistible.
The desecration rather the
[inaudible] of the desecration
versus strong symbolic meaning.
This is statement of
hyper modernity.
Now my little book that has
been recently published and also
in English thanks to Michael
Wise, is centered in Venice
as its title implies,
nevertheless my intention strives
for a wider scope namely the
destiny of historic sites,
of historic cities as contrasted
with a few dominant behavioral
and architectural models such as
the skyscraper or the megalopolis.
I'm obviously aware that
Venice is subject perhaps more
than any other city to the
potentially dramatic consequences
of climate change and
rising sea level.
This point is relatively marginal
in my book and in this lecture.
It is definitely not because
I think it is not important,
but because it belongs
to a global [inaudible]
or scenario whereby Venice's
destiny is similar to that
of other cities worldwide
including New York City.
You know, listen to this point that
is obviously critically important.
I'm proposing Venice is a
privileged vantage point
that might inspire
thoughts or considerations
on an equally important issue,
namely the evolution, shape,
and destiny of the urban form.
Ideas and social culture practices
about the city of the future seem
to be determined today by
three interrelated factors.
[Inaudible] mentioned the
unstoppable growth major cities
first and the verticalization factor
to the rhetoric of
skyscrapers second.
Both exemplified in this slide.
Let me add lastly the dissipation
boundaries affecting city
and countryside.
You see here in the wonderful fresco
in Sienna you all are familiar
with this boundary
very clearly defined.
So let me go back between
the city and the countryside,
that they're complimentary
to one another.
We may say on the contrary
that what's going on is
that the wild boundaries
of the city separating
from a countryside intimately
connected with the city itself
like in Sienna are destroyed.
And a new type of boundary
[inaudible] increasingly arise
in the boundaries within the city
as in this example from Brazil
in which the boundary is between a
gated community with tennis courts
and little pools on balconies
and they [inaudible] here.
The boundaries within the cities
between gentrified and boundary
in neighborhoods and gated
communities further [inaudible].
While the suburbs are teaming
with all the new poor as seen
in this impressive example.
What is, or rather, was the
countryside in Sienna, Florence,
or the [foreign language spoken] in
Rome is still very much reasonable
in Venice as the lagoon more
than in any other place.
This is one of the many
reasons why what happens
in Venice does not only
concern Venice but us all.
Venice indeed, because
it is precious,
it is unique, it is improbable.
It is the most improbable
city in the world still.
It is still there.
And its very singular
connection with the waters
and the mainland is going against
the blade because it is naturally
for this generation and without
cars and is a dominant symbol
and a [inaudible] of the
human nature of historic city.
Now the question is should
we preserve this [inaudible]
of space or dilute it?
Assuming that a new model, that
a mega-cities, skyscrapers,
boundaries within the city, social
economic boundaries within the city,
will it be the only possible
form for the city of the future?
Or do we have space for the
diversity in the shape of cities?
Let's say Venice is a potential
level to the litmus test where from
to look at the global decline
of historical centers often
not generalized and thought
of as being left over in relation to
the real place where new buildings,
possibly vertical are being built.
[Inaudible] shape, having a
knowledge of that obvious goal
to erase diversity,
to homogenize cities,
to substitute civil conversation
among citizens for created spaces
for citizen's machines for
production and consumption of goods.
So let us pause for a moment
to think inspired by I hope
by this thoughtful Athena.
As a better icon of the storied
city, Venice is precisely
for this reason the
most important target
for whoever [inaudible]
denying the very raison d'etre
of urban diversity.
As most convenient scenario
were to experiment [inaudible]
of social and cultural life.
But if we want to save Venice from
the offenses which can bring it
to death, it is not enough to
be indignant and to protest.
The decisive move is to elaborate
the project for the future
of this city which
preserves its uniqueness based
on what I would call a
two-phase far sightedness.
I mean the ability of, to
look simultaneously backwards
at historical legacy and
forwards, the future of Venice not
as a museum, not as a theme park,
not as a place for tourists.
But as a city for human beings,
for its own citizens primarily.
Then the tourist can come of
course but for citizens primarily.
We cannot reduce Venice
to a place of tourists
who all the citizens must
be servants to tourism
and not cultivate any
other productive
or creative human activity.
Our generation, not just in Venice,
but everywhere, has been tasked
with a great responsibility
to show that diversity
and beauty are not weighted
legacies from the past
but an extraordinary gift
to live with in the present.
An extraordinary endowment to build
upon for guaranteeing the future.
In the world in which we live we
should show that there is space
for diversity for urban mothers,
for diversity of cultures,
of lifestyles, that the urban space
as developed in Venice as well
as in other historic city does have
a right of citizenship in the world
of today and of tomorrow
because if Venice dies,
that's reason for the
title of my book,
it will not only be
Venice that falls.
The very idea of the city will die.
The form of the city as an open
[inaudible] space social life
as the very foundation
of civilization.
And let me say, also, of democracy.
Thank you very much indeed.
[ Applause ]
>> Grant Harris: Okay.
So I see the time is 3:55 so we
did start late by about 10 minutes
so let's keep rolling
a little further.
We don't have a lot of time for
questions but let's try maybe three.
All right.
Are there questions?
>> Salvatore Settis: There's
a question over there.
>> Grant Harris: Speak loudly.
>> Yes. I was just simply going to
ask what you would suggest those
of us who don't have the
knowledge of Venice that you do
but love the city can
do to help save it?
>> Salvatore Settis: Well, I think
that awareness by public opinion
in important countries,
particularly here in this country,
particularly in this city,
awareness of what's going
on is extremely important and that
influence the government bodies
that have to take decisions
about it.
And decisions are sometimes
not that difficult.
For instance, if we think about
problems of second homes in Venice,
they've been calculated
that on average people
who possess a second home in
Venice, often very wealthy people
who buy a palazzo on the Grand
Canal, but they stay in Venice
on average two and
a half days a year.
Now they are not citizens.
They cannot participate
in life of the city.
Now it is possible to reduce the
number of second homes in Venice.
Is it possible?
Yes. It is.
Because in Switzerland they passed
the law two or three years ago
by which in each city
of the Switzerland even
in smallest villages you can't
have more than 20% of second homes.
This is Switzerland.
This is not a Communist country.
So if this is possible in
Switzerland, why not in Italy?
Why nobody thinks about doing it?
Why nobody even proposes to do it?
So I think awareness,
public opinion,
and pressure from public opinion
all over the world and particularly
in this country would
be extremely important.
Would be extremely important to put
pressure on the governmental boards
who are very keen to hear
the business of developers,
or tourist organization,
or [inaudible] organization
in less inclined to understand
what the big problems are.
>> Grant Harris: I think
there's some questions that came
through [inaudible] in
the back who had -- .
>> It seems obvious that the
cruise ships need to be stopped
but obviously there
must be some desire
to have the tourist come
and spend the money.
So who could stop the cruise ships?
>> Salvatore Settis: Well, first
of all, apparently only ten percent
of the people who come to Venice on
those cruise ships finds the time
of going into Venice
and spend something.
So for most of them looking at
Venice from the highest balcony
of the ship is more than enough,
looking down at Doge's Palace
in bathrobe, that must be a very
interesting experience which -- .
But I actually never
did that so I can't tell
but for some reason
it is considered.
And there are several
projects on [inaudible].
One possibility is to bring
people in the neighboring place
like [inaudible] which is a lake
port with which is in [inaudible]
and then with the smaller or
to have them arrive somewhere,
there are several problems but the
first thing to do is to make clear
that cruise ships cannot
enter the docks of San Marco.
But you know the San
Marco cannot be entered
by those gigantic cruise ships.
This should be absolutely necessary.
Now the [inaudible] it
is called in Venice.
They have another problem.
They want to excavate a
canal within the lagoon
for the cruise ships
bringing them somewhere else.
But the excavating a similar canal
was the cause of the big flood
that happened in the same
year of the flood in Florence,
the, just in '66 I think.
So now do we want something
like this to happen?
So there is a great reactions
against this and I hope
that eventually they will
decide to do it differently but.
>> You choose.
>> Salvatore Settis: Yeah.
Okay. I think this [inaudible].
>> Do you have any thoughts
on what industries might
supplement tourism in Venice?
Obviously some industries
[inaudible].
>> Salvatore Settis: The,
in the area of [inaudible] there
was a big chemical industry
that contributed significantly
polluting the lagoon
and creating other, but to create
jobs in Venice and to create jobs
that would contrast to the
increasing unemployment
of young people which in
Italy, as you probably know,
is 38% by contrast
with 22% on average
in the states of European Union.
So this is a big problem
that goes much beyond that.
But in Venice it is possible
to imagine different activities
and particularly creative
activities,
something that works very well
in Venice is the [Foreign
Language spoken].
Something that works very well are
the universities in Venice but many,
many young people who would like
to live in Venice while going
to the university, they are unable
to do so because it's too expensive.
So it's not very easy
to have [inaudible]
in general plan about Venice.
But it is very easy to say
that if there are no attempts
at such a plan, the city
is condemned forever
which is something I'd
not like to happen.
>> Grant Harris: We'll
take two more questions.
>> Salvatore Settis: One is there.
>> There's one that you're aware
of the irony is I know you say
you don't like cruise ships.
But obviously one of the
major industries there
in Marghera is the
construction of cruise ships.
[Inaudible].
It's one of the main
industries there.
>> Salvatore Settis:
Oh, well, but I think,
I think that those cruise
ships are not built there.
I think that the presence of
cruise ships must be judged
and decided upon based on
whether they pollute the lagoon,
whether they make the
life of citizens worse,
whether they make the protection
of cultural heritage more difficult
and this is something that
is already very clear.
So I understand that problems cannot
be solved from today in one night
but I think that starting
doing something
in that direction would
be very good.
What happens instead that
whenever one of the many problems
of Venice is addressed such as by
the so-called [inaudible] the sort
of barrier to be created against
the high water, aqua alta.
You may know, it's a very long
story in the last 30 years
or so with a story of corruption,
a terrible amount of money
that has been lost and thrown away.
They've been calculated by a
book by a very good economist
who [inaudible] who is Italian
[Foreign Language spoken].
At least two billion Euros
were spent in corruption.
So if we spend in corruption
two billion Euros, why don't we,
why we shouldn't try to spend
something in helping people living
in Venice rather than moving away.
So that's the complexity of the
problem which I have tried more
in the book than the lecture
of course to give an idea of.
It's something to think about.
One more question?
>> Thank you.
Just a quick question.
What's amazing about Venice is
that it's actually still standing.
So I think my question is what is
the city doing or the government
of Italy doing to preserve
the foundation of Venice?
>> Salvatore Settis: Very little.
At this moment very, very little
and unfortunately what is the fact
that little is doing for
preservation of the lagoon
in time will endanger
the entire city.
So I think we are still in time.
It's, in making save public opinion
left and this expect to be very,
very important so I hope that you
all in this room will be among those
who are aware of the problems
of Venice and contribute
to making this awareness
wider and more and deeper.
>> Grant Harris: You can
take just one really last
question [inaudible].
>> I have a question
about new technologies.
Since you put an image
of [inaudible].
I think it needs to be a big part of
problem because a high concentration
of cruises in very, three or
four places and everyone goes
to the same place, take
a picture, and goes.
[Inaudible].
And so my question is about
new technologies and now
that there's the possibility to sort
of reconstruct a lot of these places
and I think there's a
company called [inaudible].
>> Salvatore Settis: Yes.
I know them.
I visited them in Madrid
several times.
>> So my question is what do
you think of that as a solution
to solve the problem of tourism.
Is it [inaudible] or is it?
>> Salvatore Settis: Well, I
think that building a new Venice
and convincing people to go to the
fake Venice instead of the real one,
I think this is something that
goes beyond my imagination.
I like people from [inaudible]
and I visited their laboratory
and I also made the official speech
when the big [Foreign
Language spoken] painting
which was originally was in
the Louvre was [inaudible]
which is a wonderful copy
but it is very clear a copy.
So and the copy in that
particular case is very important
because you have the [Foreign
Language spoken] is at the Louvre
and will never come back to Italy.
But seeing the [Foreign
Language spoken] painting
in a very well done
copy in the space
by [Foreign Language spoken] made
for that particular painting,
this changes totally the perception
of, in this case it is very good.
But the idea of going the
very same thing somewhere in,
you can do it in Arizona if you
wish but this would not be Venice.
>> Grant Harris: We'll
have to stop there.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.